need motivation watch a top 10 with
belief nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something greater
inside you as well you've got Michael
Jordan level talent at something so get
ready to shift your mindset believe and
not let your fears paralyze you with
Collin O'Brady and my take on his top
ten rules a success to give you the
belief that you need okay let's kick it
off with rule number one shift your
mindset that first day you know I
literally land there after all this
planning all this preparation media
press storytelling around this and I get
the out there I put my sled and I strap
in the first day and like I can't pull
my sled like I'm like like like I mean I
can move it a little bit but on any sort
of sustainable way at all and a little
bit of context and this story is that
another British explorer actually was
attempting this crossing at the exact
same time not not like sort of at the
same time like literally we were dropped
off one mile equal distance away from
each other so not only racing history
but now we're racing each other
head-to-head because the logistics are
so complex that it meant we literally
had to take the same plane the same
drop-off point on the same day like
ready go and so you know he's this sort
of you know grizzled polar veteran older
than me but way more experienced than me
as well he's you know he's crossed more
you know miles in Antarctica than any
living explorer pulling a sled and on
that first day I can barely pull my sled
this is this captain Lou I see him on
the horizon just like chillin just like
taking off just like he's like smooth
ski stroke day one like looking behind
me like oh this kid does he can't even
move on the first day and so that
question like we are the storage or tell
us of what do I tell myself in that
moment do I go like wow I am an epic
failure I'm a lone Antarctica my
competition is way more prepared than me
what did I get myself into you called
your project the impossible first duh
like I literally pick up the satellite
phone to call Jen on my wife she knows I
know she's in the details the whole
project plans I'm just like why are you
calling me so soon you just got out
there and I'm like so it seems like we
named our project the right thing it
appears that it
impossible which is like wait well I was
like yeah I can't really pull the sled
so to me it's that moment and I think we
have a lot of these moments both in that
you know large sense in this case or
many a millions ones throughout the day
small decisions of you get to choose how
to act in that moment what I've realized
is our minds are flooded with that we're
flooded with fear we're flooded with
setbacks right but in those moments like
we actually get to choose and I realized
to me I say the only question that truly
matters when facing those kind of
obstacles is how will we respond I'm
literally crying at this moment when
it's minus 25 what happens when you cry
your tears freeze to your face it's a
pathetic state they call around but I
said to myself and actually with the
guidance of Jenna who's certainly been
you know a huge guiding force to me if I
happen to mention her enough already
I'll continue to it she goes look how
far away are you from the first Waypoint
and you know my GPS I've got a four
markings on the map and I at the time
like you know I'm five four miles away
from the Fresno's and millions of miles
like okay so you're half a mile away
from the first Waypoint forget about the
thousand mile journey
forget about captain Lou that's like
already beating you in this race forget
about the media the press the students
falling all in the classrooms forget
about that you need to set an
incremental step right there
half a mile like I can see for ten miles
so I can literally see the point I'm
trying to go half a mush like get to the
first Waypoint that will make it feel
like you've made some sort of progress
around this like forget about tomorrow
forget about the next day and to me that
was just that that mindset shift so
instead of you know two things the story
I tell myself wasn't you're a failure
you always knew this wasn't gonna go
right it was like oh I'm the type of
person that does hard things to push
myself and learn and I know it's going
to be hard in fact I know I'm on the
edge of failure an inch from failure a
lot of the time but that's when I thrive
because we can I can lean into my
support system I can reprogram in my
mind tell myself different story so the
story that told myself that day was like
oh you're the guy who's gonna make it to
the first Waypoint today and then
tomorrow morning like we're gonna figure
out tomorrow tomorrow and that and
that's kind of where the journey began
not in the not in the way I hoped it
would start but in a way that you know
forced me to really start learning and
growing right out of the gate
rule number two believe my wife Jenna
who is not just as a
partner but really just the co-creator
with me we dream up these projects
together we build a non-profit around
inspiring young people and kids there's
tons of public schools one hundred and
hundreds of thousands of public schools
kids falling along this project at the
time and that's really where our passion
lies there and health and wellness now
we could talk more about that later but
anyways I call home to Jen and I say
Jenna
not just somebody at Everest we got one
mountain to go and she goes okay great
like how you feeling I'm like well I'm
exhausted I'm still up at 26,000 feet
it's gonna take me a few days to get
down and we can regroup for this next
Mountain she goes yeah and she says
something I'll never forget she goes I
actually need you to put your boots back
on right now I'm like wait what and
she's like yeah so we've been doing some
calculating back home and it just so
happens that if you can get down from
Everest today I've arranged for a
helicopter to pick you up in base camp
helicopters I'm taking a Katmandu but
there's no time for you to rest in the
hotel and evening flights can take you
to Dubai to Seattle to Anchorage and
instead of having three weeks to climb
Denali you'll have three days but if you
can do all that
you'll set not one but two world records
you can have the Seven Summits record as
well Wow this is moment where I just
laugh now I love this quote you've
probably heard it but it's a Henry Ford
quote he who says he can and he who says
he can't are usually both right one of
the ones I've lived by this moment of
like you know way I know better than to
not listen to my wife because she she's
a badass and she's amazing and knows
when to push me but I'm like alright
maybe we can pull this off and sure
enough a hundred hours after standing on
the summit of Everest I'm on the other
side of the world at the base of Denali
three days battling this insane storm
but on May 27 2016 make it up to the
summit of Denali and kid in this case
set not one world record but two world
record finishing this project rule
number three build the great team of
course I had read about this but the
extreme cold was something that I had
never been privy to so it was so cold
that the average temperature in
Antarctica is minus 40 degrees and what
this picture is I've actually taken a
cup of boiling water for my dinner and
thrown into the air and it instantly
turns into ice so that gives you a sense
of what minus 40 degrees feels like on
your body and you saw from the last
photo I'm actually have all my gear
behind me and I'm dragging it in a sled
day by day till I reach the South Pole
on many of these journeys I was
completely alone but on this journey I
had a team with me a few other people so
this is us inside of our tiny little
only shelter of a tent kind of keep warm
put a smile on her face and this next
video shows kind of the importance of
teamwork in such a hard and harsh
environment which is when you get out of
your tent in the morning it's minus 40
there's no standing around of course
there's a time lapse but over the course
of about five minutes we're packing
everything up everyone has a roll
putting it in our sleds and then quickly
moving along because if you stand around
even for a minute or two and minus 40
degrees you can immediately get
hypothermic or get frostbite so having a
really well-oiled machine of a team
working and that's a theme throughout
this entire project even in moments when
I was alone there was a team in the
background Jenna etc working to make
sure this all somehow would hopefully
get work rule number four don't let your
fears paralyze you what's your
relationship to fear fear is very real I
think that one of the external
perceptions of me if you read you know
two-sentence bio is oh that guy's a
thrill-seeker that guy's you know a
risk-taker adrenaline junkie you know
that kind of stuff he's putting his life
on the line
whereas I actually think about it very
differently which is the things that I'm
doing yes there is some implicit danger
and you know climbing Mount Everest or
being alone in Antarctica for two months
absolutely but I also think that I can
mitigate a lot of that fear by training
in preparation actually being prepared
for what I'm doing even though it wasn't
fully fully prepared clearly didn't have
the math equation quite right in terms
of the weight of my sled of figuring out
that preparation but also saying fear is
real but again not having to react to it
so was I afraid a lot being alone in
Antarctica a hundred percent so I
couldn't take a single day off because I
would have run out of food which meant
that when the winds are blowing 50 60 70
mile-per-hour minus 80 degree wind chill
would they give you frostbite within 10
seconds of having exposed skin like I
still had to be out there not for a
minute and out for two minutes for 12 13
14 hours and then at the end of that day
would I have to do I'd have to set up my
tent now
I couldn't bring any extra weight with
me it was too heavy basically what it
was so I literally didn't bring an extra
pair of underwear with me like no extra
change of clothes so I clearly didn't
have an extra tent right no extra tent
that means if I'm setting up a tent 50
60 mile-per-hour winds I tie one knot
wrong I clip something and wrong it's
not paying the ground I let go boom
tents
I'm alone in the snowstorm in the
coldest windiest harshest place no hope
for rescue like game over like the
stakes are real am i afraid in those
moments yes I absolutely felt fear like
I'm a human with all of the range of
motions ups downs fears insecurities
doubts all that kind of stuff however
I've also figured out how to program my
body to perform or at least acknowledge
go like oh I'm afraid right now because
like if I let go of this tent like I
could die
however that fear could either be
paralyzing meaning oh my god and that's
where I make a mistake because I'm so
afraid and I'm shaky and I'm like what
do I do where I go like oh I'm afraid
right now that's my body's response
telling me like the stakes are real this
is a time in your brain we need to take
that fear and channel the strength from
that fear and go oh this is what means
you need to focus right now you need to
double-check that not you need to really
make sure your systems are dialed you
need to take a breath and slow down and
all that and so it's not about being
fearless as in not having fear but it's
being able to assimilate fear to not let
it paralyze you and using that as
strength to focus or whatever the
situation may be also if you want to
have more confidence check out my 254
series it's free the link to join is in
the description below you will never
learn from people if we always tap-dance
around the truth success has nothing to
do with attention it's all about the
perseverance of somebody I override any
endeavor and I looked at it and I said
I'm not a brand I'm a person rule number
five push yourself to extremes
we got Everest you've done all these
different mountains yeah so I set the
world record for something called the
explorers Grand Slam in 2016 and so that
was one of my bigger first big
world-record projects and the goal there
was to be the fastest person to complete
the Explorers Grand Slam which is
climbing the tallest mountain on each of
the seven continents of course Everest
Denali Kilimanjaro etc as well as
complete expeditions both the North Pole
in the South Pole and these polar
journeys were just across the lost last
degree of latitude so that was only
sixth only but 69 miles to reach each of
the poles across the last degree of
latitude which seen a deuteron ad accent
unaided seemed hard at the time but now
and I've been
thousand mile journey and Erica but that
was a that project was 139 days
consecutive so all nine of those
expeditions Everest Denali etc back to
back to back to back without any arrests
139 days you broke the world record for
the fastest cumulative time while that
you know fewer than 50 people had ever
completed the Grand Slam most of those
people have done so in five years or ten
years train Ford Expedition rest between
plan the next one and I built it to do
it all consecutively throughout rule
number six unlock your full potential I
also learned that we all as humans not
just me but everyone has reservoirs of
untapped potential inside of us and can
achieve great things but quite often the
biggest thing standing in our way is our
own minds and so this opened up a whole
new sort of pathway for me in my life
which allowed me to go quit my finance
job the next day and become a
professional triathlete which far less
lucrative in the financial industry but
it allowed me the opportunity to race in
25 countries on six different continents
over the next six years which was an
amazing period of life for me and I had
always kind of dreamed of being a
professional athlete so not as glamorous
as the NBA or something like that but a
amazing experience nonetheless that I
really cherished rule number seven tells
stories I was a great athlete throughout
my life you know I was a collegiate
swimmer and raced triathlon
professionally as you mentioned and
these other world records and through
that I kind of you know in the sort of
the world the way people identified me
the way identified myself was I'm an
elite athlete I'm a professional athlete
that's what I am and I think of art at
least in my younger age I don't now but
a thing of art is like being able to
draw well or be able to compose music
both things I'm terrible at to be really
honest and so I was like oh I'm not an
artist I'm an athlete and then a couple
years ago actually when I was at Burning
Man it was the first time really where
with all of the sort of art that goes on
there that's collaborative that you can
touch that involves all the senses the
huge installations and everything and
the whole kind of environment in itself
is this sort of collaborative art piece
I was like oh our art isn't the way I
framed the word in my mind creativity is
a whole other thing and actually what
I'm doing through my projects is my
canvas just happens to be endurance
sports that's my
craft that's what I've beat on for years
and years and years but what I'm
actually trying to do in the world is
tell stories show my story and showcase
it in a way that isn't about people
watching the athlete in the arena
compete some world record but more so
how can we create stories to have this
ripple effect of positivity and impact
throughout the world so start a
non-profit that was focused on inspiring
kids to get outside and move their
bodies of active healthy lives through
our sort of storytelling and creative
mediums you mentioned snapchatting from
the some whatever it's really sharing
these stories in a way not that someone
who can be like dude coal and you're a
badass that's awesome okay like that's
you know semi interesting what's
interesting to me is when someone's like
holy Sh I've been talking about starting
that business for the last ten years but
like you actually went out there and did
the thing thank you for doing that
because I'm actually now starting that
business rule number eight be curious
for those that don't know about you you
just finished an incredible journey in
Antarctica crossing 6255 days right yeah
54 days 54 days in an unaided journey
dragging a 300 pound sled or something
crazy like this where no one was able to
touch you or support you in the process
of crossing this part of Antarctica yeah
and it was 54 days you got like a 60-day
plan yeah she sprinted the last leg
there's ten days leave yeah and it was
incredible watch this journey you've
been all over the news lately and you
were kind of racing against another guy
who was doing the same thing and what an
incredible journey man Congrats on
completing you thank you yeah it was a
it was a wild ride to say the least you
know is a night a few other world
records to my name previous to that in
the mountains but this is a world first
you know this is something that no one
in history had ever accomplished and
going back a hundred years people have
tried you know Ernest Shackleton a
hundred years ago was kind of sort of
one of my heroes one of the early
pioneering explorers it said like man
should cross the continent of Antarctica
and it's been done now in teams of
people or as well as you know using wind
aid kites dogs but it has never still
been done in its most pure form which is
so low completely alone unsupported so
no resupplies of food or full few
drop-offs and unaided meaning you know
no kites
some vehicles just this is like a man
versus nature mono e mono out there and
so it was it was a beautiful challenge
to take on as I'm really keen oh just
fascinated as myself is just tapping
into the potential that I think we all
have inside of us and I'm locking that
so this curiosity inside me as an
athlete led me to want to go after this
and I didn't know if it was possible I
literally named my project as I set off
the impossible first rule number nine
keep moving forward and eleven years ago
my life looked nothing like any of this
just after graduating from college in
2006 I took a backpack in a surfboard
and decided to head off in the world for
an adventure with no itinerary and found
myself on a beach in rural Thailand and
of course because I was 22 years old and
invincible just looked like a great
activity to partake in yes that's a
flaming jump rope and as you can
probably tell it did not go very well
for me so the Rope wrapped around my
legs let my body completely on fire to
my neck the ocean was a few steps away
so kind of with one last breath an ounce
of courage I ran to the ocean to over
into the ocean to extinguish the flames
but not before this happened which is I
had been severely severely burned I
won't make you stare at that for too
long but what must have been at least I
don't know 24 hours or so later I awoke
leaving a small ICU and there was placed
in a place in the surgery room an ICU
where there was a cat running around my
bed and across my chest which was
certainly hammering home the fact that I
was very very very hard far from home
and in a dire set of circumstances
certainly this unsanitary Hospital could
kill me and I don't know but even worse
they were giving me a ton of morphine at
the time but don't know if anyone has
been even have morphine in a hospital
maybe yeah it's not that it's not that
fun it may kind of feels like there's
insects crawling all over your skin and
it's horrible so just a terribly
traumatic experience for me and I was
really downward spiral and quick and I
was in the middle of nowhere on a small
island in Thailand and they couldn't
move me because it was really too
intense for that so luckily for me about
five days in this ordeal I ended up
having eight surgeries eight days in a
row in this small Hospital
my mom arrived to my bedside to be my
protector and so I know now that she was
crying every single day in the hallways
I'm pleading for that with the doctors
but she instead every day came into my
hospital room with a smile on her face
and era positivity daring me to dream
about the future saying things to me
like Colin what do you want to do when
you get out of here like let's set a
goal and you know me being 22 years old
at the time I was like are you kidding
me mom I'm screwed my life is over the
doctor's everyday were telling me that I
would never walk again normally because
my bat legs have been so badly burned
over the ligaments knee and ankle joints
with the mobility was really never
supposed to return and so it was a dire
set of circumstances for me but she
really kept at me every single day
forcing me to think about the future
so finally kind of buying into her
positivity I said alright mom one day
when I get out of here I'm gonna one day
race a triathlon so that was my big goal
and looking down at my legs at the time
seemed rather unrealistic I'd also never
done that before I'd never done a
triathlon but in my mind that's what's a
strong sort of able bodied person could
do and so mmm before I knew it I
actually asked her to actually X this
doctor he kind of has a crazy coy look
on his face because I said all right I'm
training for a triathlon now Here I am
I'm burned I'm in Thailand I had him
bring in some weights for me to start
kind of working my arms out just to get
something going on for me but really
that that goal gave me a purpose and so
it was several more weeks since I was
released from that Thai hospital and
flown back to Portland Oregon which is
my hometown and I still hadn't even
taken a single step at that point so I
was carried on and off the plane and
placed in a wheelchair when I got home
and the next morning I awoke in my
mother's kitchen and my mom said to me
she says all right Colin well now I know
you've got this big triathlon goal
that's great but today your goal is to
take one single step and so she grabbed
this chair and placed it one step in
front of my wheelchair she said you need
to figure out how to get out of your
wheelchair and get into that chair in
front of you it took me three hours that
day to work up the courage and strength
to do that but somehow someway I got out
of my wheelchair and sat
into that chair and the next day she
moved the chair five steps away from me
and the next day ten each day I could
take a few more steps every president my
mind was this triathlon goal of getting
back to my fitness and a little shot of
me I was a swimmer as a kid and I was a
collegiate swimmer at Yale hmm before
all this burn accident happened so I was
just kind of figuring how can I get back
to being able to move my body I remember
the day after I could walk a little bit
months into this and then one day I
could jog jogging felt like flying that
day but it certainly was a far cry from
being able to run any sort of triathlon
so it took another 18 months until I had
a shot at actually taking a shot at my
goal but in about a year and a half
after my accident I had taken a job in
Chicago in the financial industry and I
signed up for the Chicago triathlon so
about a year and a half like I said
after my burn accident I honored my goal
by diving into Lake Michigan and
swimming a mile for the start of the
triathlon and getting on my bike riding
at 25 miles and then putting my running
shoes on and running to the finish line
crossing that finish line for me was a
very joyous moment having honoured that
goal that I set in the tie hospital to
not only walk again thank you and then
there was one other crazy surprise in
store for me that day I hadn't just
finished the race but I actually had won
the entire Chicago triathlon beating out
about over 4,000 of the participants on
the day certainly was a crazy moment for
me and although the the win was
certainly a nice cherry on top the first
thing I thought about were those moments
in the tie hospital and wondering what
would have happened had my mom not
forced me to set a measurable goal and
to keep moving forwards and I'd learned
this to me a really invaluable lesson
that I've taken with me through the next
decade of my life which was that life is
going to test us with setbacks no matter
who we are but we have every opportunity
to key to choose to keep moving forwards
one step at a time
rule number ten the last one for a very
special bonus clip is conquer you
mind was the middle of the night almost
a year ago I struggled to breathe each
step taking longer than the last I
fought my way upward at the cruising
altitude of a commercial airliner focus
I thought keep pushing forward the
combination of a hundred and thirty days
of consecutive climbing the negative
60-degree windchill in the actual
physiological state of my body fighting
back at 28,000 feet on Mount Everest
summit ridge was pushing me to my
breaking point get ahold of yourself
Colin I desperately tried to regain
control of my mind but doubts fear and
pain swirled in my thoughts one step at
a time I thought in the darkness my
headlamp only illuminated the few steps
in front of me focus one step at a time
I began counting my steps one to ten
steps could have fooled me
I felt like ten miles I felt my body
giving up I was hopeful that the
daylight might give me some strength
after a long night of climbing but the
sunrise only illuminated the two-mile
drop-offs on either side of me I was
again being tested by the biggest
obstacle of all my mind but this time I
wasn't alone
Jenna's words filled my head my mom's
words filled my head remembering those
labored steps after my accident filled
my head strengthened by those thoughts
my mindset shifted and my body forgot
its weakness I felt the surge of energy
each step taking me closer to the summit
and after a few more hours of hard work
I gazed out on the most magnificent view
from the top of the world we got any
Timbers fans out there
[Applause]
now I have a social bonus clip with
Colin on how to do the impossible that I
think you're really gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the three
point landing questions let's go from
just watching a video to take an action
here we go question number one where do
you need to conquer your mind number two
what three things are you curious about
and want to explore and number three
what fear are you no longer going to let
paralyze you now if you like this video
and you're going to take immediate
action give me a hashtag believe down
the comments below you said something
very close to we are the story that we
tell tell ourselves talk to me a little
bit about self narrative especially in
light of that day one when you started
the journey to cross Antarctica where
you hit real doubt right off the bat
like what what were you saying to
yourself and how did you manage to keep
going yeah I mean I I love that phrase
we are the story we tell ourselves I'm
such a such a big believer that you
could have a pessimistic you can
optimistic standpoint you can sort of
like I said for the longest time I was
like I'm an athlete I'm terrible at art
and now I'm like wait I'm an artist like
this is creative it's just if it's just
reframing in my mind but that first day
you literally you know my wife and I
have planned this project for well over
a year and kind of been out in the
zeitgeist of exploration as being an
impossible project a couple years prior
to me a guy died attempting this
crossing and a couple years later one of
the most prolific polar explorers went
out there and after 54 days we ran low
on food and supplies and actually had to
be rescued out of there before he fully
ran out of food and people were like
look this projects impossible because
it's this math equation of you can't
carry enough and your sled without being
resupplied because it's too heavy to
move it at first to get across the
continent but if you take too little
you're gonna run out of food somewhere
on the other side trying to make this
Traverse so it's a square weird math
equation people like it's impossible so
we literally Jenna and I decided to name
our project the impossible first not as
this some like cocky ploy like people
call us impossible like we're so much
better we can do it it was like
literally like this might be impossible
but I saw on your wall over there you
know you miss 100% of the shots that you
don't take it's like but we're willing
to try like we're willing to engage this
process and if we fail in trying
something that is seemingly impossible
well we're sure shake gonna learn a lot
along the way along this incredible
journey so like let's go after it let's
call it the impossible first and what we
happen to figure how to get to the other
side
heck yeah even better
if you want to see the top 10 I did on
rich roll check out the video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there I'm happiest and most alive when
I'm butting up against the outer edges
of my pain threshold for the last two
years
[Music]